of all the things that seem Dynamic
about India whether it is its young
population whether it's rising GDP
whether it's the increased consumption
capacity of the Indian middle class all
of those things are based on projections
in the future and India continuing its
current growth rate and so it's a longer
term Ploy I don't think anyone who tries
to sort of milk a relationship with
India in the short term is going to
succeed whether you're a company or a
country but in as much as you know this
lays some of the groundwork for a future
post brexit uh British sort of global
trade agenda it only makes sense to to
Hitch one's wagon to India for the
longer term